[Aplausos]
[Música]
e
fake news así es como se dice ahora pero
detrás de estas dos palabras se esconde
una lucha política donde se juntan la
desinformación el espionaje los agentes
dobles e incluso los asesinatos esto ha
existido toda la vida pero sin duda
amigos la edad de oro del espionaje fue
la guerra fría la pugna entre las
democracias occidentales y el comunismo
soviético tras derrotar juntos a la
alemania nazi y fue precisamente en
alemania donde esa lucha produjo los
resultados más terribles tras la segunda
guerra mundial alemania quedó dividida
artificialmente en dos estados al oeste
la rf a la república federal construida
como una democracia occidental más al
este la república democrática una
dictadura comunista del gusto del
kremlin
[Música]
así que como os podéis imaginar además
de separadas las dos alemanias estaban
enfrentadas tenían dos modelos políticos
completamente opuestos el muro de berlín
fue el símbolo de esta división una
barrera para evitar que los ciudadanos
de la rda huyeran a occidente pero
amigos el régimen comunista no se limitó
a levantar un muro no querían tener
controlada a toda su población para ello
se creó el llamado ministerio para la
seguridad del estado más conocido por
todos como la stasi uno de los mejores
servicios de inteligencia del mundo una
especie de policía secreta cuerpo de
espías dedicado a localizar a todo
enemigo del estado dentro de la rda y
también a combatir a los enemigos del
comunismo en el exterior amigos la
información es poder y hoy en visual
político vamos a ver la influencia de la
stasi en la historia de alemania atentos
[Música]
la vida de nosotros si algo bueno tenía
la rda es que la telebasura nunca
hubiera tenido éxito con 90 mil
empleados en la stasi y al menos 600.000
informantes entre la población pues ya
me diréis quién iba a ponerse a ver gran
hermano porque amigos la propia nba era
como una especie de gran hermano gigante
90.000 empleados y 600.000 informantes
casi 700.000 personas una locura y si
tenemos en cuenta que la población de
este país era de sólo unos 16 millones
de habitantes las cosas se ponen aún
peor aproximadamente una de cada 22
personas colaboraba con esta policía
política
[Música]
la urss creó la rd a finales de 1949 y
cuatro meses después este nuevo estado
creó la stasi con un objetivo mantener
en el poder al partido único el set el
partido socialista unificado un partido
marxista leninista que estaba a la
izquierda de lo que hoy en día llamamos
izquierda el caso es que el éxito de la
stasi como agente opresor fue indudable
mantuvo bajo control a la sociedad de la
república democrática alemana desde su
creación hasta 1939 casi 40 años después
de hecho la mayor revuelta interna que
tuvo la rda la huelga de junio del 53
duró menos que un vídeo de tick tock
claro que la pregunta que podemos
hacernos es como lo hacía la stasi
pues tenemos que partir de dos premisas
primero lo controlaban todo y segundo
hacían lo que querían con absoluta
impunidad y no no estoy exagerando la
stasi dominaba todas las facetas de la
vida podía hacer que no encontrarás
trabajo o que no terminarás tus estudios
si por ejemplo mostraba algún tipo de
desafección al régimen para eso jugaba
un papel fundamental la red de topos que
tenían infiltrados entre la sociedad
para que os hagáis una idea
prácticamente en cada edificio había un
vecino que suministraba información a la
stasi y sobre cualquier comportamiento
sospechoso quien entraba a quien salía
si alguien cambiaba sus hábitos de
repente lo que fuera además todas las
comunicaciones estaban vigiladas la
stasi y leía las cartas y escuchaba las
conversaciones telefónicas y para
investigar a los posibles disidentes
quedaba reservado el seguimiento
especial metían micrófonos en sus casas
por supuesto sin órdenes judiciales ni
control
alguno de por medio los ciudadanos no
tenían garantías en la rda
[Música]
las personas desaparecían de un día para
otro en la rda no había ningún límite a
la detención preventiva se estima que
300 mil personas pasaron por alguna de
las tres cárceles de la stasi y
desgraciadamente tal y como os podéis
imaginar las muertes que se atribuyen a
la stasi también se cuentan por miles la
prisión central de la stasi fue una
herencia de la ocupación soviética todo
el mundo temía acabar en alguna de sus
celdas las llamadas su voz sí exacto
como el submarino celdas humedad sin luz
exterior y con una luz mortecina
constante para que el uso no supiera ni
siquiera qué hora era los presos no
tenían ningún contacto con nadie que no
fueran sus captores pero hay más las
celdas especiales de castigo celdas con
el suelo cubierto de agua o las paredes
forradas de caucho para aislar de
cualquier ruido
terrible amigos el control que tenían
las taxis sobre la sociedad llegaba
hasta tal punto que se sabe que en
ocasiones robaban ropa interior y
toallas usadas no te quitaban todo y lo
guardaban para que llegado el caso los
perros pudieran rastrear a cualquier
disidente
[Música]
por supuesto esta falta de escrúpulos
también se mostraba en su acción fuera
de la rda por ejemplo la stasi puso en
marcha la estrategia de los espías romeo
a ver os hago una pregunta que podía
faltar en europa tras la segunda guerra
mundial
exacto hombres jóvenes pues por eso
mismo la stasi reclutó en los clubes
deportivos en los gimnasios y
asociaciones juveniles a los candidatos
más atractivos luego les daban formación
en codificación de mensajes técnicas de
grabación etcétera también conseguían
que fueran grandes conversadores que
fueran cariñosos y con sentido del humor
llegado el momento los mandaban a europa
occidental especialmente a la rf y cuál
era el objetivo de todo esto puedes
obtener información a través de
cualquier medio incluida la seducción sí
sí lo habéis escuchado bien pero casi
mejor que os lo cuente uno de los espías
más famosos de la historia
markus wolf que dirigió el servicio
exterior de la stasi durante tres
new life looks especiales
en el mismo importe de información el
mvp del pas
curioso no os parece por supuesto ahí no
quedaba todo
[Música]
a veces la stasi compraba directamente a
políticos occidentales en 2006 sería
conocer el famoso archivo rose holtz el
archivo rosen hold contienen los nombres
de un total de 48 diputados y una cosa
es segura cinco de ellos han trabajado
con la stasi destacan julius steiner de
la cdu y leo wagner del csv en 1972
ambos diputados fueron comprados en el
voto fallido para retirar la confianza
al canciller socialdemócrata brand por
50 mil marcos alemanes cada uno brand
siguió siendo canciller amigos aquí
hemos tocado un tema sensible
billy brandt y la stasi
tras la segunda guerra mundial brand fue
el primer canciller de la república
federal alemana que pertenecía al
partido socialdemócrata de hecho
hablamos de uno de los personajes más
importantes del socialismo en el siglo
20 brand fue el responsable de la
ostpolitik una estrategia política que
apostaba por la apertura de la república
federal alemana a cooperar y establecer
relaciones con el bloque del este bloque
por supuesto el liderado por la unión
soviética incluida a la rda en cualquier
caso la actitud amistosa de berán está
hacia la rda no fue correspondida por la
dictadura comunista en su afán por
controlarlo todo la stasi consiguió
colocar un topo hunter guillón como
secretario personal del canciller alemán
durante cinco años pasó por las manos de
un espía de la stasi toda la información
sensible de la república federal alemana
y de la otan
[Música]
también claro esta información sensible
del propio canciller
la detención de guillaume sacó a la luz
los trapos sucios de abraham con una
afición desmedida por el alcohol y las
mujeres escándalos que llevaron a brand
a dimitir como canciller sin embargo no
acabaron con su carisma y de hecho
aunque ya había dejado la política fue
el portavoz de los socialdemócratas en
la primera sesión del bundestag tras la
ramificación de alemania
digamos que aquel día willy brandt
derrotó a la stasi con elegancia y allí
reyes está deberán y go de ser usted es
el cierre blockbuster su madre
hilando en capítulos así pues si fueran
como a bp de vdv técnicos tales
fundamentalistas de fútbol comercial
[Música]
siempre se dijo que winter visión fue el
espía de la stasi quien más daño hizo a
la rca pero en visual político down en
visual político creemos que no atentos
me llamo bol bol
junio de 1967
berlín occidental está emergiendo un
movimiento estudiantil que arremete
contra las nuevas regulaciones
universitarias del gobierno contra la
guerra de vietnam y contra las
dictaduras en todo el mundo por este
motivo la visita del sha de persia reza
para lavín causó un gran revuelo hubo
una importante manifestación contra la
opresión del sha y amigos no olvidéis
que entonces irán era un estrecho aliado
de occidente especialmente de los eeuu
pues bien el caso es que la
manifestación estaba siendo pacífica
hasta que una contramanifestación ataca
a los estudiantes la policía decide
cargar para disolver a todos los
manifestantes a multitud se dispersa es
el caos benno ohnesorg estudiante de 26
años es perseguido junto con otros
estudiantes por policías vestidos de
paisano en un callejón el inspector karl
heinz currás le pega un tiro en la
cabeza estamos ante el punto de partida
en alemania del famoso mayo
del 68 el asesinato de benno ohnesorg
sublevó a decenas de miles de
estudiantes en todo el país currás
siempre aseguró que disparó en defensa
propia fue absuelto en dos juicios claro
que quizás lo peor de todo fue que la
policía prefirió el corporativismo a la
verdad la policía de berlín encubrir las
circunstancias de la muerte de ones or
que este es un evento clave en la
historia alemana en 1967 el estudiante
menor recibió un disparo durante una
manifestación
aparentemente premeditado la
investigación de investigadores y
editores del spiegel ahora lo ha
demostrado la policía cubrió al tirador
calkins currás e incluso el cuerpo de la
víctima fue manipulado para muchos
jóvenes alemanes el estado se había
convertido de repente en algo malvado y
cruel así que la mayoría se unió a lo
que sería el movimiento estudiantil
desde el 68 pero atentos porque algunos
incluso prefirieron la lucha armada
nunca
[Música]
y
este estado fascista nos quiere matar a
todos la violencia es la única respuesta
a la violencia esta es la generación a
auschwitz no puedes discutir con ellos
gudrún ensslin gudrún ensslin fue una de
las líderes del grupo terrorista rap
fracción del ejército rojo creo que
fácilmente podéis imaginaros sus métodos
robos secuestros y asesinatos de grandes
personalidades del mundo político y
económico pues bien el caso es que esta
banda terrorista se nutría de los
estudiantes universitarios de corte
marxista de la rca pero seguro que
estáis pensando que unos chavales no se
convierten en terroristas de la noche a
la mañana
ustedes
así que la pregunta es quién les ayudaba
pues por supuesto la stasi
que les dio apoyo económico y material
les enseñó a manejar armas y explosivos
para la stasi y la lucha contra el
capitalismo lo justificaba todo incluido
esto
[Música]
el asesino donde surgiera un espía de la
stasi sí así es
en 2009 se conoció que aquel policía que
asesinó a un estudiante era en realidad
un agente de la stasi su nombre en clave
era otro bolt todo esto nos lleva ahora
a preguntarnos y aquellos jóvenes
alemanes que se inclinaron por el
terrorismo hubieran actuado igual de
haber sabido la verdad los líderes de la
fracción del ejército rojo murieron en
prisión en el 77 así que nunca sabremos
si se hubieran considerado víctimas de
la manipulación de la stasi ahora bien
la pregunta es cómo demonios es posible
que se tardarán cuarenta y dos largos
años en conocer la verdad pues bien
atentos el mayor puzle de la historia
dos cosas nos quedan de la rda treinta
años después de su desaparición una es
el puñado de récords del mundo en
atletismo que aún nadie consiguió batir
la otra es el archivo de la stasi
imagina lo que puede haber ahí después
de 40 años
espionaje abusos y delaciones lo malo es
que el archivo el gas está así y los
récords de atletismo de la rda tienen
algo en común posiblemente nunca
sabremos toda la verdad
[Música]
tras la caída del muro de berlín la
población de la red de asalto en masa
los cuarteles de la stasi para conseguir
sus expedientes para entonces el
personal de la stasi ya había conseguido
destruir una cuarta parte y como las
trituradoras no daban abasto recurrieron
a las bañeras ya los cubos para sumergir
los expedientes y hacerlos papilla
y cuando llegó tenían más bañeras libres
los empleados de las taxis dedicaron a
rasgar a mano cada página se calcula que
rompían cada hoja en 13 pedazos así que
el panorama que se encontró la gente
cuando irrumpió en los cuarteles de la
stasi fue desconcertante se hallaron más
de 16.000 sacos en total 600 millones de
piezas para juntar el mayor puzzle de la
historia 45 millones de documentos
esperando a ser recompuesto sos parece
una misión imposible puedes esperar un
momento porque esto de ser alemán tiene
sus ventajas y sus inconvenientes
[Música]
los empleados de las taxi fueron
metódicos en la destrucción del archivo
que cometieron un pequeño gran error
todos los pedazos de un expediente
acababan en el mismo saco ninguna mente
fue lo suficientemente creativa como
para repartir las piezas entre
diferentes sacos para dificultar aún más
una posible tarea de reconstrucción aún
así el reto es enorme y es que 30 años
después sólo se han reconstruido 500 de
los 16.000 sacos
[Música]
con la reunificación alemana hubo voces
partidarias de destruir el archivo de la
stasi de una vez por todas claro que
finalmente prevaleció la necesidad de la
gente que vivió aquella dictadura de
saber la verdad quienes aspiraban porque
les habían castigado que el vecino les
traicionó que tenían contra ellos lo que
sea pues bien para llevar a cabo esta
labor de reconstrucción alemania creó la
comisión federal para los archivos de la
stasi cuál es el problema pues que a
finales de 2013 nos enteramos de esto ex
personal de la aste así todavía trabajan
los archivos de la antigua policía
secreta de alemania oriental quizás
ahora os podéis hacer una idea de por
qué se ha tardado tantos años en saber
la verdad sobre ciertos asuntos si es
que en algún momento llegamos a
conocerla del todo en fin amigos esto
era la stasi una de las policías
secretas más terribles de toda la
historia un servicio secreto una policía
política que controló a prácticamente
todo
toda la población de la rda poco se
escapaba de su control pero llegamos
hasta aquí la pregunta es para ti qué
historia de espionaje os parece más
espectacular la de unter guillón o la de
oto bolt creéis que mayo del 68 hubiera
sido diferente en alemania de haberse
conocido entonces que la mano de la
stasi estaba detrás de todo déjanos tu
respuesta en los comentarios y este
vídeo te resultado interesante
no olvides darle al botón de like i
suscribirte adiós al político un saludo
y hasta la próxima
[Música]